welcome to this video
yeah this is some a book review again I
haven't done one for some time but it's
really yeah high time that I do a book
review on the book I'm going to talk
about right now because um I got this
book recently and it's truly one of the
most entertaining and fascinating
opening books probably that that I ever
read
so all I'd say to read an opening book
at some but difficult to say what yeah
to a book that I browse through and took
a look at to see what ideas it's going
to offer and this book is some about the
opening which we see right now on the
board about the the mora gambit in the
Sicilian defense defense sometimes it's
also called the Smith more on due to
American player our Ken Smith who I
think played it in the 70s mostly with
was quite some success but he had a very
bad tournament with itwe lost to three
Grand Masters in a row and after that
well it didn't exactly help to UM to
give this opening a great reputation
yeah and here we come to one point about
the Morrigan but it's not an opening
that enjoys a particularly great
reputation very often the attitude of
strong players is that black simply
grabs this gambit pawn like like here
and yeah well it's more or less an extra
pawn for nothing which is yeah very
often what good player think I must say
that I belong to that category as well
at least I I did belong before I got
this book however thought that this
opening is yeah more or less incorrect
so that it might give some fishy
compensation sort of but it's not really
a serious opening but looking at this
book I must
I changed my mind about this and I think
though this opening is really a very
interesting field for study and this
book can provide really an amazing
amount of interesting attacking ideas
especially if you are looking for an
aggressive weapon against the Sicilian
but you don't want to really yea learn
all the main lines of the open sister
you know you don't think that you find
some sharp weapon within the anti
Sicilians which is it's not easy if you
look for on sort of antes de Cillian
which is really aggressive then you have
a hard time because those openings are
mostly yeah very non-confrontational and
but the Mora is obviously very
aggressive you sacrifice a pawn for
quick development yeah but let's get to
this book again and yeah a few words
about the author the author's I'm an
American International master mark
esselman he's rated about to 450 as an
in-season it's late 20s and has played
the moral gambit for yeah most of his
chaste life I would say he's got game
examples which easily
yeah from 10 years back when he was yeah
just out of his his junior years and he
played it as a kid also did that's in
the book um yeah this book is about 350
pages thick so it's not very lightweight
kind of kind of book it's got lots of
content and especially absolutely
amazing amount of new and interesting
ideas in those very complicated
positions um what I'd like to do is to
give you some impressions about the kind
of lines that are suggested so I don't
want to give everything away but what's
in the book but just to give you some
idea what what kind of things might
happen um I also present you one
complete-game and this is the game or
you already see the name say Assam
against the loop from Bailey from 2011
but they'll quickly through them through
the chapters here one very popular way
of playing against the Mora has some yet
the sort of the line that is often often
called the Siberian trap we can we can
look at this here the idea of this set
up for blankets to play this move and
trying to play 94 so h3 94 and black
wins instantly as this is a checkmate
yeah but then this is still played I
mean I played it myself as a kid I
remember I was fascinated by the strap
and tried to win games with this but the
it's got a very interesting antidote and
this is not b5 Queen Bee a dandy 5 very
aggressive sacrificing yet another pawn
and yeah what should like do he's he's
taking it here in this game I'm just
just to show what happens yeah and now
we already see that
White has a very strong attack in the
works with Bishop f4 possibilities of
checking on c7 it's um it's very
dangerous for black and in fact he's got
a sample game here where he wins very
quickly say 95 it's just a couple of
more moves Bishop g5 so that didn't
check on c7 and e6 is very close to
being made and you've got Roxy one
coming up so um why it's got a very
strong attack I don't want to analyze
this really just want to show what kind
of fun position you sometimes get with
this opening now why does got everything
developed it's very cute here on the
fifth rank and I need to to change the
color here of my my marks all right now
it's
so I'm very fun position and yeah rook
takes c8 is the threat at 27 checkmate
and yeah like try to try this but Lowry
resigned because um yeah it's just just
terrible what's happening here let's say
for example this and with a very very
CUTE checkmate in the end yeah just just
a quick example of this sub Burien trap
can go back to the starting point
um yeah he's got two chapters on the
stiffening and setups which look like
this pawns on d6 and e6 this is a rather
rather strategical branch of the Mora
why doesn't have many quick wins coming
in this in this line but she still seems
to retain some long-term compensation I
would say that um I was really inspired
by this book and trying to try to play
the morrow I bit myself if you watch my
channel regularly you'll see that I
played a couple of moral gambit games
recently most in blitz and I don't know
maybe one or two rapid games and I also
got this once in a while but it's really
seems like white has adequate
compensation um yeah that's one branch
in the book which really am left me
completely stumped this is this setup
and this some chapter is some applique
art into the deep yeah and yeah the
amazing thing is some that white in this
position just castles and after deform
should like play before which obviously
yeah it's the materialistic but also
very a principle move then he actually
suggests applying 95 he not even only
suggests that he played it himself
against pretty strong opposition's like
international masters and it's very hard
to believe at first that this should be
get adequate compensation for the piece
but he offers a very detailed and and
very young inspired analysis of this and
it seems that even what the computer
check it seems to lead to a really
interesting position of the White has
yeah very good compensation it can look
like this in fact this ninety-five
sacrifice is not at all uncommon in the
Sicilian so it's maybe not such a big
shock that it's that this case also
might be working but still you're pretty
much amazed that this is possible it's
in fact not sacrifice which immediately
earns you any material gains in the near
future or any direct mating attack very
often it's a rather positional sacrifice
where blacks Bishop is a problem white
sometimes just take this pawn and then
tries to get a knight on c6 or just
increase the pressure so much that black
um yeah really tumbles down yeah I don't
want to show a complete complete game
but yeah I tried to actually yeah
analyze this a bit myself because I had
a hard time believing this but just as
he mentioned in the in the text here and
the computers obviously have problems
appreciating this kind of sacrifice but
very often after couple of moves they
yeah they
show that while indeed has compensation
it's still pretty amazing
um and I must say that the book is
absolutely loaded with beautiful
attacking games and analysis it's a it's
simply a joy to read because you have so
many great detecting games um even if
you don't play 1.e4 simply simply for
the pure fun of it it's it's simply a
great book it's also written in a very
very funny funny style with lots of
quotes and movie references if you're a
movie fan then you'll see lots of good
lots of fun fun stuff in them
yeah what else is there that's a Chicago
defense it's quite interesting you learn
something new every day I didn't even
know this kind of stuff existed the
Chicago defense looked something like
this
where black correctly gets a look on
this happen to cover the pawn yeah I
must admit that this looks a tad
unnatural to me but okay it's obviously
something that is played um the general
kind of idea that he offers is like this
and then pushed the f-pawn I mean you
can simply count them count em P here
white is fully developed and blacks cut
outs pieces on the back rank it's still
relatively closed this position let's
say it's not apparent that white would
mate who in the next five moves or so
but he certainly has ideas to open up
the position so this is another defense
where he suggests a very aggressive
approach then what else is there we got
the dragon set up which really surprised
me I mean I didn't know anything about
this opening I must say and I was
surprised that the dragon and some the
dragon set up let's say something like
this
that this setup really has some serious
problems against the Mara I thought well
what the heck black might be able to
play this why not but this kind of stuff
is already very annoying so this move
oughta might even be a problem for black
it's possible that if like wants to go
for a dragon kind of setup that he
possibly needs to go along these lines
where he offers the interesting move and
pretty amazing if five of course this is
just hanging but they as he said he is
coming up and this leads to a
compensation position worldwide having
compensation form for the pawn the
dragon doesn't really seems to be a huge
problem yeah then there's some a very
big chapter devoted oops devoted to this
setup which he calls the professional
the professionals choice the choice of
professionals Matt G to e7 and I don't
want to go into this too deeply because
this was played in this game that I'm
going to show you as someone against
when veiny um yeah that's also um
yeah the tailor defense and them the
tailor defense as is something like this
with the idea of really developing this
bishop if possible
so if white would waste the temple with
h3 then black can simply play he seeks
that has won a tempo compared to his
given it on lines at least this as
possible on yeah he's got Bishop f4 as
the idea against this um yeah this is
actually a quite important defense it's
often given in books but it still seems
too
to lead to to fund attacking positions
in general I will say that if you intend
to look at this opening and play it you
shouldn't be the kind of player who's
counting as pawns in every position you
really need to yeah get going and be
willing to sacrifice material even even
pieces in the opening it's maybe
sometimes a bit of a gamble but you
always need to take need to take into
account that very often you simply have
the initiative the good thing about this
gambit in general I must say is ok and
sacrifices the pawn but you don't really
make any concessions in a positional
kind of way in a strategical kind of way
the only slight problem with the missing
c-pawn is that the d4 square and at some
time the d3 Square might be weak this is
very abstract at the moment but it can
be effective if you look em just for
example if you look at the the main line
here of the skinning and setup you see
that this knight deform might be an idea
of black managers for instance to
exchange this Knight and it's got 90 for
coming this is the only positional
drawback of this opening the only other
drawback is well yeah your porn down for
this very quick development and yeah
very smooth start of the game we get all
your pieces out quickly but you don't
really um concede anything in a
strategic way let's just compare this to
another gambit let's just compare to the
King's gambit for instance if you look
at the Kings gambit white has made a
huge concession from a positional point
of us as king is really weak it will
stay weak the whole game even after
castles as this pawn as long it is
it exists will threaten white skin in a
way and you have problems developing
this Bishop especially if you consider
that black might play g5 at some point
then you cannot really develop freely so
it's an entirely different kind of
gambit where white really risk some more
by weakening himself and then by
sacrificing a pond here it's not just a
pond it's really a position the risk
that you that you get yourself into
which is not the case with the Mora here
you simply have a nice development and
my brief experience I'm only playing
this for like a couple of weeks um here
my brief experience also shows that
quite often you have so much activity
that even if you play something which is
not 100 percent correct maybe or not the
best kind of moves you often have enough
activity to to compensate that and even
can't play on if you're not really
winning with the direct attack you still
don't suffer from some long-term
satirical problem so for instance in one
correspondence game I would have to move
water and simply failed to look at this
book to be honest I just played a couple
of moves under him and learned
afterwards that I made a mistake already
and then I had to play on with the porn
down but I had so much activity that I
still could draw the endgame with the
porn down simply because you have those
1 1 or 2 weeks for Tempe that gives you
enough activity to to draw the game so
it's not so terribly risky in this in
this aspect okay
yeah there's Talos defense what else is
they are the fine gold defense is also
in there so that's basically all kinds
of setups that are usually suggested are
covered that's a less important defense
that it's not in the book somehow the
editor sir
didn't get it in there but this is
covered
already on the quality chest on co uk
website as a PDF supplement it's not
very important online but it's it's on
there from a repertoire point of view
you also of course need to take into
account that like it is not obliged to
take the pawn and thankfully he devotes
about about 100 pages to the more are
declined and this is mostly the move
Knight f6 and d3 where black doesn't
take the pawn
what do you three is actually the move
that I played myself as black when when
I faced the Mora because I simply never
bothered to learn the acceptance of this
gambit
I played the Mora accepted once with
black and lost against 2200 player and
after that has simply simply always
played t3 but this kind of position yeah
it's just a sort of Marazzi binds where
white is slightly better in some way so
it's not a big deal not if there's an f6
though here just transposes to the c3
Sicilian and he offers quite some lines
with this this variation it's not the
only line that black can play black can
also play only six and so on but this is
the gambit style line that he that he
analyzes so it very much fits in the
general yeah flavor of the book to
recommend some interesting attacking
line against Knight f6
there are also some some versions of the
declined which which interesting like
this and the fun thing is if you look at
this if black insists on not taking the
pawn
which he sometimes does then he will get
problems with the cook will be three I
wasn't really aware of this idea and
black really has some problems of course
he can transpose into this this dragon
thing that I have mentioned before but
if he tries to stay without the area or
out of the area of the morrow accepted
then yeah he probably will get to get
some problems yeah it's very nice and I
can really I can only recommend this
book I have no serious criticism it's
simply a very entertaining and
inspirational book because it contains
so many great attacking chess so much
great attacking chests that even if you
think okay now you always play Knight f3
and g3 and stuff like that simply a
person like me I also don't play one in
foreign tournament games then even then
you would simply enjoy the the great
attacking ideas in there okay to give
you some some more crude idea what might
happen if you played them all I'll show
this game SML against convenient and I
hope you don't know it because it's
really really great to look at and you
might um already have the suspicion that
it ends in a white win and you're right
I don't want to then I don't want to
make any sense
get in any suspense into this so a
salmon really beat on Luke from veiny
who's been rated close to 2700 for a
decade or even longer so I'm a really
great upset that he managed to to play
yourself let's see what happens from
really plays the night G is seven
defense and esselman plays Bishop g5 and
this is really a key move that you
reckon
he thinks that anything else really am
isn't enough to travel black the idea of
Nagi is happiness just to get the night
of g6 and sort of control f5 and of
course Bishop g5 yeah prevent this and
provoke some kind of reaction from black
from Vinnie now played f6 to which white
just drop the Bishop back and now Knight
to g6 so black has a very good control
of i-5 white cannot play a 45 in the
near future and now he played Bishop to
b3 and this is has a very aggressive
idea which we see very soon if I'm
really not play to b5 probably not
expecting anything bad to happen but
here white has an absolutely amazing
move I mean it's if you have got some
experience in the Sicilian then you
might think about this move but it's
still very amazing that it is working
white now played Knight to d5 again the
sacrifice that I showed them some time
before in another line but here is also
working and yeah black needs to needs to
take it basically why does threatening
Bishop d6 he could play some move like
rook b8 on it's a 95 move like rook b8
to cover the b6 square but still have
white just place our a strengthening
move what to do after that so difficult
to to tolerate this Knight so when many
just just grab this piece it takes d5
Knight to e5
and now the key move d6 this is really
the idea of the sacrifice this move
opens up this diagonal and blacks King
stays in the center and it's very
difficult to remove this pawn black
cannot go here because of the bishop
this looks fun so it's it's really
difficult to get at this pawn and as
long as this pawn is there and this
bishop is there how do you get the King
out of the middle it's very difficult
and in fact black has really hard time
to find any defense here so been really
really
yeah walked into a sort of minefield
here this was prepared by a salmon but
just the amazing thing is black hasn't
made any really obvious mistakes but it
really can get very hairy for black
quickly okay we should be seventy plate
and now white took only five the
intention of course is to to open the
position he played F takes d5 now if
black would take with the knight then
white simply increased increases the
pressure on the e-file and simply black
place without those pieces he cannot get
the King out of the middle and what what
should like do here could try this
attacking the pawn but simply this move
protects everything and you've got F for
coming you've got this coming it's
terrible
this attack wall will need to lead to
mate in the very near future
so this is why I took with the F pawn
and now of course no time to hesitate
you need to open it up F for busting
open the F file so that the rook also
joins the attack
yeah if Nvidia now plates Queen to f6
here you had a better defense probably
yeah the very risky looking move take
some is better but okay
the thing is very often in those gambit
openings where you get some attack
it's simply super difficult to defend
those positions because you're under so
much pressure as black that we are bound
to move to make some mistake simply a
computer might be able to defend lots of
positions but a human player it's very
very difficult okay played Queen to f6
and now SMN took only five like needs to
recapture not much choice and now we've
got yeah the next really of hammer blow
coming coming at like it's a Bishop g5
with double exclamation mark again yeah
it's a very simple idea checkmate
but of course all kinds of stuff is
hanging so we need to check the captures
what is happening what would happen if
black takes on on g5 yeah that's
actually the front move Queen e1 check
King b8 if black can goes Bishop e7 then
there's just move coming
nice isn't it I did segment so after
Queenie one you need to look at King to
d8 but of course I've got this also and
this is checkmate and this obviously me
also very nice the Queen taking the
square we're away so I'm great simply a
great great way to head to win a game
what else is there blackouts it could
give a check but what can sum to anther
was rook f2 it's basically the same line
with like taking on g5 so they cannot
take this but also there's a simple
thread rook e1 and as mentioned the maid
thread also so I'm what when really
played which should be seven is really
the only move to care to make it someone
more difficult for black and for white
obviously Bishop f7 check yeah I needs
to go to d8 and now white can simply
capture only seven yeah and now we see a
position where yeah where white after
Queen d2 has sacrificed one little pawn
and he's got such a devastating position
I mean there's this idea rocky one on
his heaven
Ruby want to get on this heaven it's
simply an amazing attacking position yes
you can imagine yeah black didn't
survive this but it still has some very
nice points knight c6 rook t1 simply
getting on d7 and yeah black defended
with Queen f5
and yeah here white has some a direct
winning sequence which has someone found
bishop to have for the ideas that Queen
d6 c7 as is deadly so he he took them
the peace Queen d6 and King d8 and first
glance you might think okay maybe black
can't survive this but that's the next
next sacrifice coming group takes c6
Bishop c6 and Quincy six yeah it here
then Valley resigned as some yeah black
simply has no defense at all let's say
rook c8 the only move that you can think
of at the moment then I've got this
coming winning the Queen made everything
everything at once yeah okay this is
checkmate and this also so it cannot go
up g8 and what what should black play
it's a queen a force also made so it's
that it's made everywhere so a fantastic
attacking game that as someone here
pulled off against went villi I can only
recommend to to look at this a little
bit more especially this kind of
position after oops I'm sorry it's a bit
too quickly and this kind of position
with the pawn on d6 and this Bishop this
is really something you need to learn to
appreciate that this is really a very
strong compensation because black cannot
cannot move his pieces to meaningful
squares it cannot get the King out of
the middle so I'm I think from strong
player it's pretty clear that this is at
least very dangerous hard to tell them
if it's winning or something but you
would immediately see okay it's getting
really hairy but this is still something
very difficult to appreciate if you're
in this position that 95 is really
so strong so yeah great effort here by
SM oh yeah as for this book I can simply
say yeah get it have no idea why you
shouldn't really even if you don't play
1.e4 it's just great entertainment and
inspiration for attacking chest
um yeah thanks for watching this video
and if you've got suggestions for other
book reviews then feel free to use the
comment function here on YouTube I will
do some some more book reviews in the
near future and there will also be some
book reviews that are not on openings
but I must say that some opening books
really a little bit more than just about
openings as some and it's the case here
it's really also a great book about yeah
romantic attacking chests in a way he's
SMN is really a fan of the romantic
attacking players and it really shows in
this book yeah on every page yeah thanks
for watching